you have any like BuzzFeed personalities
that you would want to meet everyone who
watches BuzzFeed has a crush on Eugene
well I never read any of those process
we just might have to hang out at queer
prom together because you were gonna be
flowing out to LA and you are part of
our official from court
[Music]
queer prom intro interviews scene 5 take
1 growing up in Philly was difficult I
would say my entire junior and senior
year were not like hell I wouldn't say
their hell but they were exhausting
there was a lot of interrogation there
was a lot of like wrong name on the roll
call and then when I was like oh that's
not my name they were like was that me a
lot of side comments very dismissive
tell me all the slurs I know every
single one I know them all and I know
all the tones you could say it in to
make a teacher think that you weren't
being hateful just making a joke high
school is hard for everyone I'd say but
when you're trans people expect you to
have endless patience and endless
kindness for their [ __ ] they want
you to explain everything very calmly
and when they get it wrong they want you
to comfort this I moved to Santa Cruz
like two three weeks ago I was moving
out of like a rocky household on the
outside someone looking in my don't say
that my family's as supportive as I
think they are because I still get
misgendered I still get dead named I
still I'm asked a lot of really invasive
questions I came to live with my father
and his partner with my best friend Lee
growing up in Cape Town is different I
come like from a Township which is like
very poor like black community and like
everyone's just like usually below the
poverty line depending on like way you
live and like being a black trans like
Oh queer person in South Africa is like
you kind of like a very closeted because
it's like a very like violent and
repressive like society the slam poetry
community is like much better here in
America than it is like in South Africa
and so like we have like there's this
competitive like slam poetry like youth
international competition and so we both
made the Philadelphia team I like poetry
is very intimate and very like you know
you just
Spinelli Afilias like oh my god that's
hurt and so you kind of have to be like
that for each other and then that's like
we basically became friends like that
California is easier than Philly to be
trans in at least for me because there's
a lot more options for trans health care
and there are a lot more trans people in
general just walk around with like
piercings and I'm just like you and I
say Paige I've never done a prom
everyone else has gone to prom I don't
have money to get a suit are we kidding
a rental maybe maybe but my mom and I I
wouldn't say that we're poor but we're
very we're very low-income and she
didn't want to spend money on something
that it's frivolous you know and prom
was considered something that was
frivolous it was it was extra but it
wouldn't have happened anyway because
cost and then you know she went down at
my house and I had to leave very quickly
but even then I don't think that my prom
was a completely safe space quickest you
better pay your freakin swings dude
because you are coming to Busbee square
prom yeah hello my name is Christopher
Underwood I live in each white Michigan
I'm queer I'm here and I'm going to
queer from pretty excited as you can see
I'm pretty feminine so when I was
younger a lot of kids would like
bullying me for it and say things like
oh that gay black people tend to be very
religious oriented so it wasn't very
talked about other than like you know
you know make fun of somebody or they
insult somebody this is my school got
kind of be careful when you're walking
to and fro because there's gonna be
these poop everywhere which was one of
many friends that I've had that
supported me and encouraged me and made
me feel as though I could be gay I knew
that if I did decide that I was gay or
whatever or felt as though I changed my
mind about that then I could tell them
and I fear that I would be ostracized or
alienated that heard it too that he told
everybody is
for us cuz I asked them you know half
does he anyone know things like that and
he said everybody for a long time I
didn't want to tell her just because I
thought that she was very homophobic
because she is also a pretty religious
person and sometimes we would talk about
LGBT type issues she wasn't the most
knowledgeable like I was before you know
coming out and he showed me out
completely
no family anything not eating together
no nothing and that's that's been a
battle ever since my thinking was oh if
they're really homophobic they not just
like forget about them or whatever
because yeah and I thought that I was a
great person to talk to
I even went and got a degree in social
work go figure that could counsel anyone
on the streets but my son don't even
trust me that come to me that's
different for me I just assumed that she
was homophobic but I feel like looking
back she just didn't know and I regret
not telling her sooner you know we'll be
like all in the hog feet and he'll be
like proper hug or or I'm a bottom on TV
see that see that sit my friends going
to career from are so excited for him I
have lots of girlfriends and lot of
straight guy friends and I love them all
so much but sometimes it's like I feel I
want somebody else that could completely
relate to me so I feel like I want to
find that here in Los Angeles like we
were prom even though these stories were
incredible we had to take out the
stories where they were closeted because
BuzzFeed such a public platform we
didn't know if it would be dangerous for
them like we didn't know if their
communities would be accepting that's
all you can be paying for next weekend
cuz you're gonna be here in LA for
BuzzFeed square problem
we wouldn't want to bring somebody into
the fold and then send them back to a
community that was unsafe for their
family that wouldn't be supportive not
everyone's parents were accepting so we
just had to make sure that we brought
out people that were really embraced and
had a loving community
yeah or people who were 18 my parents
always told me from the moment that I
was like actually able to comprehend
that I was adopted that I was adopted
yes they do it's in there I did not see
eye to eye with my parents on literally
every level we used to have to meet at
the fence between our houses because we
were neighbors and we called it fencing
and then slowly we graduated to pole
dancing in her basement
they really formed me as a person so we
had elementary school together and then
I transferred into her Catholic school
for my sophomore year so I was ready to
shoot my brains out so I left but uh
took you an extra here to well it wasn't
really bad choice but for my first three
years of high school I went to a
Catholic school in Massachusetts and
they kicked me out just this past summer
when they found out I was trans and I
went to a public school and at that
public school I have been so blessed I
came here literally not knowing I was
going here only for days look look at
this display
everything has been very very very nice
my father over there so on my dad's
birthday I came out as gay to them and
my dad took it well but my mom
completely freaked I tried to repair the
relationship as best as I could and
we've been making progress ever since
but then I came out as trans almost a
year ago now and that put an even bigger
splinter in our relationship like I knew
her situation I knew it wasn't really
good at home for her so I kept like
pushing and saying like why don't you
just move into my house and so I started
introducing the idea to my parents and
then finally miss stubborn decided to
listen to my advice and make herself
happier and decided to move in an
address on my fake titties then the
[ __ ] is ready to slave today I have
recently been taking some steps towards
finalizing and making concrete my
transition I plan on going to Town Hall
pretty soon when I get back to start the
name change process then go to Fenway
health which is in Boston and they're
known for their transgender health care
so I'm gonna go there and I'm gonna
hopefully start on HRT it's very nice
because like I never really had a
supportive system around me like in
middle school or whatever I didn't
really have friends let alone friends
that would accept me I've never been
able to be like fully open with anyone
other than Quinn I've always been so
focused on like I said everyone else or
maybe school and academics and all of
these things that I was getting caught
up in and finally it feels like all of
the struggle with gender sexuality other
aspects of my life has been leading up
to this feels full circle I have some
bad news
I can only invite saige to prom because
say do you have to invite Caitlyn
yourself you and I are both super
involved in theater
this is the backstage Kaitlyn wasn't
really like out yet to be like we're on
the low like talking for a little bit
and then when he decided like it was
time and getting like dyed her hair red
generally have anything yeah Kaitlyn got
an undercut just to go all-out we went
to a photo booth in the mall and took a
picture where we were kissing real
specific we're so gay we posted the
picture of I kiss and everybody's like
hey everybody's gonna see us we're gonna
be like the talk of the school nobody
talked about us we just thought it was
like we're I guess probably like one of
my favorite views of the city all down
here you can see one of the main roads
into the white and then that's the rock
river and that's a select Kaitlyn mine
go to so like I grew up in like a really
conservative family and I didn't really
have any outlet to any type of a
community I think I remember just
sobbing I was just like sobbing in my
room my mom was like well what do you
want to talk about I was like I think
I'm gay and my mom was like what then
when I talked to her about the BuzzFeed
thing I was like really nervous because
we haven't really talked about that you
know she's mowing the lawn I made her
stop the lawnmower I was like mom stop
mowing I have great news and I like come
over where and I'm so excited school
just finished I'm like and I got
accepted so like I'm going you know to
like LA and stuff and she was like I was
like isn't that so exciting the twos
like well honestly it makes me want to
throw up and I was like I make you want
to throw up and she was like well not
you like homosexuality makes more
but mom I'm a homosexual so like well my
sexuality that's me I make you want to
like throw up then you know and we got
in like a like a big fight all about it
because we had kind of had to just make
a line and be like you're not gonna know
about things you're not gonna talk to me
about things I'll keep that part private
from you and we have to respect each
other and respect that we're gonna stay
separate and like do our own things and
so we basically like made that
commitment and then we didn't talk about
it again until I left so can we do our
handshake really quick yeah my dad is
here he's pretty chill I talked to him
about it in my house like can you come
with me like would you be down for this
and at first he thought it was a scam
that's a girl I don't know if I can get
off of work changed my schedule in six
seven days you know I said you've got it
do it yeah this is the chance that's
really important you got to do it it's
when things are important to her we just
make it work you might don't talk about
at a time I mean we've talked about it
like more than ever here being around
other kids he's like asked me more
questions about like pronouns and things
do I totally understand now no but am i
learning yes no matter where in life she
goes or what choices she makes I want
her to know I'm there no matter what
well I'm not excited because there's
gonna be all gay people and we were like
one of the only like couples like that
you know in our school and I'm excited
to wear it like exactly what I want and
to be feeling really confident like next
to Caitlyn and knowing that she's
feeling good
we'll also at our school proms it's just
a grind pit that's it there is no other
dancing happening you're either grinding
or you're sitting at the tables and so
we said it's tables a lot I'm hoping
that they'll be different you are
Rowan right well you are definitely on
the VIP guest list congratulations you
are coming to our queer prom but at I'm
relatable teenagers my high school looks
like a mall
it really does like me I mean I went
through the whole deal with my school
and
they told me that I wasn't able to use
the men's room anymore so after that I
went home and started educating myself
and learning about Connecticut's
non-discrimination laws and really like
putting myself into that situation and I
had a lot of help from my friends as
well and we really worked towards
getting like figuring out which
bathrooms we wanted to have unlocked and
how we were going to unlock them getting
the bathrooms in the school was the hard
part learning to accept that people are
going to use them for other things was
it was I was a lot I don't know
sometimes when I'm in able to get in
here to change like a divergent close or
individual close because I was occupied
because people like to make out nice oh
it's just kind of like hit or miss when
it comes to this one but we at least
have a space and that's what I wanted
Rowan is my fiance's stepchild from his
previous marriage sort of mom Nikki
being curious and wanting to learn more
about what I had to say and what I had
to say for myself just helped me open up
more as a person and it encouraged me to
do more than I thought that I was able
to do my Connecticut parents though
they're very loving and very very very
much there for me they're a little bit
unaccepting when it comes to my gender
and that's been a struggle with me with
them for the past two years there are
people that are related by blood that
are really family at all and people that
have zero connection to you as far as
DNA goes that you walk through fire for
so you make your own family finally
grown family last minute when you're
sort of kid tells you about it 3 seconds
before it happened
ok you know at the senior meeting they
tried to tell us that free diploma it
had to say when it said like in school
records so bless up I just changed my
name in the school so I don't have to
have the good name on the school diploma
I'm not going to round prom because I
mean the school itself like the
administration and faculty are very
accepting and it become very
accommodating to trans students after
multitude of different situations but
the students of my senior class don't
exactly accept
for who I am a majority of them just
aren't nice to meet it just not a safe
situation for myself to be in so I just
I'm gonna keep myself out of that
situation this year and I mean they're
promised better
no one is like the least reactive person
in the world I know that sounds terrible
but there's just never much emotion
there right so I'm constantly like well
we're just free and mm-hmm like just
like typical teenager no reaction and so
when you popped on camera the reaction
that I saw out of this when I didn't
know existed like I was like there's
emotions and so seeing that I can't wait
to see what happens tomorrow I'm going
to be in California like soon I'm packed
Abbadon we're flying all the mounts of
Los Angeles where they have no idea
what's about to happen next we still
have a few surprises up our sleeves here
at BuzzFeed square problem lady
you are the official queer prom court
best friends for life right folks
[ __ ] that's in vogue we have fun
[Music]
you